- [Interviewer] Okay. Lisa?
- Hm?
Yes.
- [Interviewer] So, I saw you
in the morning, this morning.
Sleeping in your furniture
blanket on the sidewalk.
Is that where you sleep every night?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Where
do you normally stay?
- Different places, across the street.
- [Interviewer] Oh, but
basically on the sidewalk?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How long have
you been here at Skid Row?
- Nine years.
- [Interviewer] Nine years,
and where are you from originally?
- Long Beach.
- [Interviewer] Long Beach.
What got you into this situation?
- I got stranded down here.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- [Interviewer] You have-
- They left me stranded out here.
- [Interviewer] Who left you stranded?
- One of my friends.
He's no longer my friend.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
He just took you here and
dumped you, and that was it?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Great.
What problems were you
having earlier on before?
- When mom kicked me out
when I was 13.
- [Interviewer] Your mom kicked
you out when you were 13?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Why is that?
- Because I was bringing
too many guys over there.
- [Interviewer] At 13?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So, you
were very promiscuous
at an early age.
- Yeah. Well, I got
raped by 10. Five and 10.
By my real dad and my stepdad.
- [Interviewer] Your real
dad, and your stepdad?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Both had
sex with you at what age?
- Five and 10.
- [Interviewer] Five, and then 10?
Wow.
Tell me about like, where
did you go at that age?
When your mom kicks you out?
- They put us in MacLaren Hall.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry, say that again.
- MacLaren Hall.
- [Interviewer] Claren Hall?
- [Interviewer] MacLaren
Hall. Where is that?
- That's place where they put youngsters
when they take away from their family.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
- DPSS.
- [Interviewer] So, you lived there?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Without any parents?
(yawns)
- [Interviewer] For how long?
- Until they-
(coughs)
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- Until they move us on.
- At what age? A certain age
they probably just
like, they set you free.
- Yeah.
18.
- [Interviewer] 18.
(coughs)
- [Interviewer] And then
at 18, where did you go?
- On the streets.
- [Interviewer] And tell me what it's like
living on the streets.
- It's no fun.
- [Interviewer] On your own, I mean.
- [Interviewer] What
kind of stuff happens?
- You've just gotta
panhandle for your food.
- [Interviewer] You panhandle for food?
What kind of stuff happens
to you here on the streets?
- Rape.
- [Interviewer] How many
times have you been raped?
- Shit, too many.
(yawns)
- I've had a guy put a nine
millimeter up my pussy.
(car honks)
- [Interviewer] How many times
do you think you've been raped?
- Too many. Maybe about 15.
- [Interviewer] Oof.
- [Interviewer] Are into any of the drugs
that are here on the street?
- [Lisa] No.
- [Interviewer] No drugs?
(indiscernible) but I'll
smoke a spice joint,
but that's it.
- [Interviewer] But you're
not heavily addicted
on that as well?
- [Lisa] No.
- [Interviewer] When you
were being molested as five,
or as a preteen, what did
your mom, did your mom?
- [Lisa] She didn't believe me.
- [Interviewer] She didn't believe you.
That's a rough childhood.
- [Lisa] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How do you see the world?
I mean, do you see the world
as a good place, but you
just see it as something-
- [Lisa] Yeah, but the people are in it.
They're mean.
- [Interviewer] It's a what?
- [Lisa] The people are
in it. They're mean.
- [Interviewer] The world is mean?
- [Lisa] The people that are in it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. The people.
What do you like to see for your future?
Where would you like to be in five years?
- [Lisa] Have my own place.
- [Interviewer] Have your own place?
Where do you eat? At the shelters?
- [Lisa] I don't eat at
none of the shelters.
I'm scared of the food.
They poison the food there.
- [Interviewer] They poison the food.
What do you think they put in the food?
- Some kind of poison, so you get sick.
- [Interviewer] So, where do you eat?
- Like I said, I panhandle for my food.
- [Interviewer] Do you drink at all?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No drinking.
(indiscernible) and that's about it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- It's almost time to go back?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I'll
take you back in a second.
Tell me about your family.
Are they still around?
- I have no family.
They're all dead.
My mom, dead. My grandma's, dead.
Everybody else is dead.
- [Interviewer] You mentioned
you had a brother though.
- Yeah, he's an asshole.
Sister too, she killed my grandmother.
She's an asshole too.
- [Interviewer] Do you have friends here?
- [Lisa] I'm ready to go back,
cause I don't feel good.
- [Interviewer] Okay,
let me take you back.
Thank you for talking to me.
- [Lisa] You're welcome.